and we need to do those in parallel so
that by 2024
all the technologies all the
capabilities will be available and ready
to fly
astronauts to the surface of the moon
edl entry descent landing has always
been
an integral part i mean an important
part of discovering another world or
learning more about other worlds
is that just as important as laying on
the winter surface because it really
doesn't have an atmosphere compared to
the martian surface well the martian
surface is actually harder to get to
because it does have an atmosphere
but we are using the moon as a proving
ground essentially the
the doppler ladder the precision landing
technologies that we need to get
astronauts to the surface of mars which
is
the end game we want to demonstrate on
the moon
and then understand how they perform and
what we need to do to extend those to
the to the mars surface
and so that means for example when this
technology matures this is actually
deployed
it'll probably fly on missions prior to
that and we'll
see test data and verify all that uh
functionality even ahead of the
astronauts arriving ab absolutely there
are things we can do
with dr lidar on the ground here on
earth
to develop it and improve its
capabilities and we are doing that as we
speak we can do it on the ground or with
aircraft
or sub-orbital launch vehicles we're
going to fly the doppler lidar on a blue
origin new shepard
next year and then we're going to take
the doppler lidar
on two small robotic landers and
demonstrate it at the moon in a fully
autonomous sense before we put it on
the system that's going to carry the
astronauts down to the surface i
understand there's a
project called splice and that's where
you have the hazard avoidance the
the the navigation.pro-lidar and all the
sensors that are part of this
this program right splice has a number
of different precision landing
technologies including terrain relative
navigation
which we actually use on earth here but
you use cameras to define waypoints and
understand
visually where you are we don't have a
gps network at the moon so we need other
ways of navigating down to the surface
we've got a hazard detection capability
so when you get close to the surface you
want to be able to look and see where
the
rocks and slopes and even craters are
and avoid those you may remember neil
armstrong and
apollo 11 he was literally within about
30 seconds of running out of fuel
because they flew over a big crater and
he didn't want to
set the lander down in the crater so we
want to do that we want to be able to do
that autonomously
with with the hazard avoidance
technologies and then obviously the
doppler lidar and the doppler ladder is
really about
precision guidance velocimetry and
position
so with radar systems we get position
and you have to derive the velocity and
rates of the spacecraft
but the the doppler ladder gives us a
much more precise
laser-based capability to pinpoint the
landing site and understand your
velocity and rates
and your position as you get near the
surface and i'll tell you the beauty of
the ndl
technology is it has tremendous
potential for earth applications as well
so we're developing it for this very
specific spacecraft human landing system
but it has applications here on earth
potentially to drive autonomous cars
with aircraft marine applications it has
a really broad base
spin-off capability that people are
looking at very seriously
now i know that doesn't drive what we do
but that's got to be really
a good feeling especially on the
engineering and science standpoint to
make these breakthroughs
meet your objectives but then at the
same time
actually open up opportunity for a whole
host of different applications and that
that's actually
always been part of nasa's mission not
necessarily explicitly but if you
look at all the spin-off technologies
that we have we've developed
that we use here at our daily lives at
earth it's a tremendous investment
and this is probably one more and that
long list of things that you'll see
in the uh you know in our daily daily
lives well speaking at ndl you had a
chance to
to learn more about it absolutely i had
a chance to sit down with farzine the
principal investigator for
navigation doppler lidar and talk to him
about the specifics of how it works
farzine navigation doppler lidar when i
hear the word doppler i think of like
weather radar how is that different for
navigation
doppler lidar well it actually uses the
same
principles that are used in weather
radars they call them doppler
right because it uses doppler effect and
the
doppler effect is essentially when an
object is moving
it causes a shift in the frequency or
change in the frequency of the radiation
in our case we have a laser radiation
and on the vehicle when we're traveling
we are shining the laser beam to the
ground and as we are moving
it causes the doppler shift and from
that we can get the velocity of the
vehicle
this sensor also uses the same laser
beam
to get the position or the distance to
the ground
and by transmitting multiple beams in
our case we do three beams
we can actually figure out what the
direction the vehicle is traveling
but of course in this case you're using
lidar so
how does the ndl actually work okay
the ndl in general provides position
speed and direction of motion
these are the parameters you need for
navigating
you use that when you drive your car
right you use your gps and your
speedometer on the car
so this is the same type of things now
of course when we go to other planets or
we go to the moon
there are no gps so we have to have an
onboard sensor to give us position
and velocity in formation and that's
what this system does
i understand that most of the time we do
this using radar
but this offers some advantages that's
true
you mentioned weather radars the radars
are also
used on vehicles space vehicles in
particular
to measure the same type of parameters
you know position
velocity your speed and direction you
are traveling
however laser provides significant
advantage over radar
being a much higher frequency means that
it's more precise the radar diverges
and the laser beams are pencil beams
that
mitigates a lot of issues that inherent
with radar system so it's both precision
and data quality that this provides
and this makes a lot of sense with
spacecraft because as you said we're
going to be going to
other moons planets types of surfaces
that we're not
already very familiar with was that part
of the thinking when you started
developing this technology well when we
started actually the reason was that
when we were talking to the engineers
who are building these vehicles to go to
mars
and other places we hear a lot of
complaints about the performance of the
radars
so that triggers for us to start looking
at alternatives
and using laser was an obvious choice
so that's how we got it started and so
throughout this development of course we
are working with those engineers
in order to come up with the best
optimum design that we could
and that's kind of the process that we
went through
when it comes to the moon and perhaps
mars do you have to
do anything different with the system to
handle different atmospheres or anything
or is this a one-size-fits-all kind of
system well when we as we are developing
these for a space
we try to envelop all the applications
so we don't have to
make design changes from going from moon
to mars
so we try to design it such that the
same
sensor system that can be used for both
applications or other places in the
solar system
so as we prepare with artemis to go to
the moon
where are you guys in the development
timeline i mean you have a working model
where's what's the status yes we are
working on the working model right now
it's almost done so the first
engineering units
are going to be demonstrated on two
commercial landing missions in 2021
so throughout this we are going to be
keep improving it making it more robust
so for the artemis would be hold out
more reliable
to ensure that the mission is successful
and that's really interesting too
because by flying on these commercial
missions
you're actually getting a flight
performance and
actual real data to help iterate the
system
absolutely this is quite a luxury for us
because normally
uh when nasa developed systems they go
through a bunch of tests
you know in the laboratories you know
doing vibrations they put them in the
vacuum
they run them over different temperature
they radiate them
you go through all of those and you
still have a little bit of a
discomfort when you go to the space
having this demonstration
is extremely helpful to us as a
developer
and it's also helpful to the engineers
that they would have more confidence in
these sensors they would have all this
data they know exactly how it's going to
perform
so it's a quite valuable experiment
and joining us back now in the studio is
franklin fitzgerald
and and franklin you know uh you
actually had a chance to spend
time with farzine and the team over the
past several months shooting b-roll and
covering a lot of the tests
tell us about that experience yeah chris
uh several months ago we got a call
and they started talking about hey we're
gonna be uh
putting this together and um we actually
went over to the laboratory where they
were assembling the ndl the box that we
keep talking about the small suitcase
box that's the engineering unit that
they're uh
building right now absolutely and after
it was assembled
uh they said hey we're gonna be putting
together several more boxes
but the one that they completed they
started to do testing on it like
vacuum testing and thermal testing and i
documented that
at some of the laboratories here at
langley but the third test that they
called before was the
test that they did at the langley air
force base where they use the
lasers that we have here models on the
on our table
to shoot a target down the runway in the
back of an
open cargo van yeah yeah i know yeah i
know they improvised
but the the the van was so far away i
couldn't even see
the cargo van with my naked eye but when
i looked through my telephoto lens of my
camera
you could see it and you could see what
they call
atmospheric turbulence or what looks
like uh heat coming off the surface like
a mirage
exactly and and farzine told me that as
the lander approaches the surface
you have atmospheric turbulence uh but
the lasers can
work through that to get an accurate
location and land like it's supposed to
and with all these tests franklin i mean
you guys would call them up and they
seem to be
working constantly on this project it
was
it felt like it was around the clock and
in one test in particular
the vacuum test i called farzine i said
farzine uh are you gonna be available
at 10 o'clock this morning he said i'll
be available at 10 o'clock this morning
10 o'clock tonight
you can come at 3 o'clock in the morning
we're going to be doing around the clock
test for the next couple of days
uh in the vacuum chamber so there were
technicians
working around the clock we know it's
important because
this ndl unit is going to be going on
two clips landers
you know in a year or so so they have to
be ready so they have to be working
around the clock to get it ready around
the clock and i think that's interesting
too because a lot of times we hear about
the technology we see it demonstrated
and you forget about the actual hours
that it takes by not just one and two
people but a whole team
to get this testing done so it's ready
to fly they haven't been working on ndl
just for a couple years this has been a
long process i mean they've been going
back to from the pre 2008
working on this and i had a chance to
sit down with glenn hines who is the
chief engineer for
ndl and he talked about that history
hey glenn thank you for being on the
show today to talk about mdl uh we've
been trying to get you on the show for
the past 13 plus years
glad to have you well thank you so much
for having me you know farzine did a
great job
talking about uh ndl what i want to do
is kind of look at the timeline
let's take us back to the beginning and
to do that i got a little cheat sheet
here
of course i have to have on my little
board here starting back
uh you know in 2008 uh when you started
this
uh this project tell us yeah let's get
started
so actually the project started a little
bit before 2008 okay barzing's uh
ideas and uh vision of this particular
instrument
but our first helicopter flight of it
was in 2008 i was out in the desert
we worked that project with jpl it was a
huge system at the time it was
like saying the size of a refrigerator
and then we eventually flew it on the
erickson sky cream in 2010.
that's huge that's a big box yeah and it
was a very difficult environment to fly
in
there was a lot of vibration on earth
and sky crane and it was still big it
was around 60 kilograms at the time a
size of about a half refrigerator okay
but then we started miniaturizing it and
we built what we call our gen 2 system
and drop the weight down from 60
kilograms down to about 28 kilograms and
made it the size of a rack mount unit
we flew that on some helicopter tests
and did some successful flights
and then eventually we flew that same
box on the morpheus vehicle in 2014
okay we flew that at the kennedy space
flight center
and it was working in closed loop at the
time with the other systems
on board what that means is the vehicle
took off by itself
autonomously picked out a safe spot to
land
and i found that and then autonomously
flew down to a hazard field that we had
built down at the end of the runway
and the vehicle landed there all by
itself so this was the first
test of the system yes in a sort of a
simulated lunar landing environment
exactly this was a progression of
moving the uh instrument from being huge
to being small enough to be able to fly
to support these landing systems
and these tests proved out not only its
capability
but it proved that we could also do the
engineering to make it small enough to
fit on
vehicles and we made it one more
incremental step after the morpheus
flight and we made it into a size of a
toaster
effectively that's what we called our
gen 3 unit and we flew that on the
mastering vehicle back in 2017
and that's leading us up to what we're
building now what we call the
engineering test unit
we're going to make it uh robust and
resilient enough to work in space
so what would you say if you take us
back to 2008 and and beyond
what was probably the the biggest
engineering challenge that you had to
face
during that time the biggest engineering
challenge was the uh
size of the box getting it small and the
forcing function for that
was the computing system there's a lot
of high-speed computing
that goes inside the box to make this
thing work you've got lasers you've got
optics you've got all the components in
there
but you need to get all the data
processed
in real time to get your answers out in
real time so that the vehicle
can react to it can use the instrument
data to fly that normally takes a lot of
computing power
and we were able to put that onto a
board the board we built here at langley
to fit inside the box and enable it to
shrink that is pretty much defining the
footprint of the box now
so from an engineering perspective
that's probably been our biggest
challenge
there are other sub-systems in there
that we've done put a lot of time and
effort into making them
better but that's the biggest one from a
size perspective
in nasa as an agency we develop a lot of
cool technology that we use
in space but then a lot of that
technology can be used back here on
earth
how could ndl be possibly used in
terrestrial applications oh that's
that's an excellent question there are a
lot of different ways that it has uh
usage right back here one of them is for
autonomous cars
you know you see that as a up-and-coming
emerging technology a small version of
ndo
can be used to track the speed of
vehicles very precisely
in theory you can also track objects
around the vehicle also so you can use
it to some degree for
hazard avoidance for the vehicle there
too but giving it a very precise vehicle
speed
is of utmost importance to any
autonomous ability it needs to know
precisely how fast it's going
let's kind of fast forward to next year
where are you going to be when uh your
your ndl system is the descent stage of
those two landers
and they're going to about the lane on
the winter surface and ndl starts
working and it's working beautifully
the state will be in is the state of
happiness
that's the state we'll be in we will be
extremely excited extremely elated that
this has
worked successfully well glenn thank you
so much for taking the time out today to
kind of give us the brief history of ndo
and the technology
i'm i'm hoping you know i know i know
you're gonna you're gonna do a
spotlighting on the moon
yep and i know you're gonna do one on
mars one day yep but what i want to see
is i want to be able to drive in a car
autonomously without driving knowing
that glenn and farsi and the team have a
instrument on board that's getting me
from a to b yeah excellent i
hope to see you that day soon all right
thank you so much chris thank you
i'm very excited about the ndl
technology for sure but this autonomous
driving stuff
is awesome and if these guys don't
deliver i'm going to call them
personally see if they'll set up a car
pool with me because i'm ready to avoid
the traffic situation
uh get some productivity on the road hey
you know one of the biggest
challenges that they're dealing with is
getting it down from that
suitcase size box to even smaller to
work inside of vehicles
the technology has already been
transferred and they're working on it
actually close to here at langley where
we were well don't forget walt said at
the beginning of the show he talked
about spice
because remember ndl is part of a bigger
suite of instruments
so you imagine not only having ndl but
then you have the
terrain relative navigation built in and
then you have the hazard of winston
detection
one day you're gonna be driving and you
get some some type of
obstacle in front of you it's gonna
drive around it and you have to worry
about touching the steering wheel
perfect
let it go on its own you know it's
interesting because that size reduction
they're talking about getting the
the basic box down to the size of a can
of soda
so just think of there's the lander for
artemis and things like that but how
many other landers that are going to be
involved in space exploration
that can use that same technology now we
do have some of that same technology in
our cars today we have the side view
uh lights that let you know that people
are next to your spot
but that's using cameras but this is
more precise this is better technology
and hopefully that will be incorporated
in other things besides cars and jets
absolutely absolutely now chris what do
you think about the long-term prospects
we've taken a cena technology like this
and it's being developed and deployed
what's the future look like
using this technology yeah i i can't
wait till we have those two eclipse
missions
uh where the ndl will be flying on the
landers
hopefully we'll get successful data and
eventually if we send humans in 2024
they'll be on the on the human landers
and then eventually as we get on to mars
this will be a staple for all the
technology all the landers that will be
sent out
so so right now we're doing a show on
technology that'll be part of that first
return to the moon that we're
we're we'll have in 2024 and then
eventually
landing on mars were you guys going to
be in
2024 you know what i'll probably be
at the kennedy space center uh doing
some programming doing some live shows
uh with you and you probably and
hopefully hopefully
yeah yeah and um it i think we're just
going to get those
goosebumps that we had for uh the many
milestones that we've witnessed over the
years
here at nasa you know i i was alive
when man stepped on moon on the moon but
i was very very young so i i didn't
remember it like i remember the shuttle
mission so
uh this is going to be very interesting
and i'm looking forward to you know the
difference is going to be
what's uh for 2024 he'll have his aarp
you know what that is absolutely right
but you know look it won't matter what's
really interesting is all this
technology that we see
in development now is going to be riding
on the lander on our part of artemis
right taking the first major step in
this process and we're all going to get
to witness it
that is one of the most exciting things
that i can think of in terms of nasa
in a long long time and i'm excited
about so i really don't care where i'll
be and knowing this
technology right here is is the part of
artemis
you're watching nasa edge an inside and
outside look at all things nasa
a record-tying spacewalk to upgrade the
space station
the station crew receives a new shipment
of supplies
and looking forward to seeing ingenuity
take flight on mars
a few of the stories to tell you about
this week at nasa
on july 21st nasa astronauts bob behken
and chris cassidy
conducted a nearly five and a half hour
spacewalk outside the international
space station
they upgraded station systems and
prepared the outpost for future
equipment
to deploy experiments into space bencon
and cassidy have joined michael lopez
alegria
and peggy whitson as the only other us
astronauts to complete
10 spacewalks on july 23rd
an uncrewed russian progress supply
spacecraft launched to the station from
the baikonur cosmodrome in kazakhstan
several hours later it arrived with
almost three tons of food
fuel and supplies for the crew our mars
2020 mission is targeted for launch
july 30th from cape canaveral air force
station in florida
the mission will carry the mars 2020
perseverance rover to the red planet
and the ingenuity mars helicopter this
technology demonstration which has
completed its series of testing on earth
will make history's first attempt at
powered flight on another planet the
very next time it spreads its wings
really our job isn't done until we see
the same
test flight being performed at mars so
next time we fly it'll be a mars
but that's our ultimate goal this one
will go yes
you can learn more about ingenuity at
go.nasa.gov
mars helicopter this is emblematic of
the greatness that comes from these kind
of exploration
initiatives administrator jim
bridenstine and other nasa leaders
joined a july 20th virtual discussion
with the space foundation
the event highlighted how nasa's artemis
program for the moon
and our mars perseverance rover mission
are helping us prepare for human
exploration of mars
technology development has already begun
to enable a crude mars mission as early
as the 2030s
capabilities being worked on range from
powerful propulsion systems
to next generation high-tech spacesuits
to pressurized rovers
astronauts can live and work in for
weeks
check out go.nasa.gov mars tech
for more about these and other space
technologies nasa is working on
to make mars science fiction a reality
nasa's planetary protection office tries
to ensure that missions to mars
and other places in the solar system
that might have life
do not carry too many spores cells that
could reactivate and
transport earthly bacteria this is
especially
important for a mission such as mars
2020 that will collect
samples for possible return to earth
the latest episode of our gravity assist
podcast
at go.nasa.gov planetprotect
has more about planetary protection
including what your hand sanitizer has
in common with nasa's clean rooms
that's what's up this week at nasa for
more on these and other stories follow
us on the web
at nasa.gov tuan
[Music]
how do you make sense of something you
can't see this
is the electromagnetic spectrum where
light travels in waves
without it the world you know could not
exist the human eye can only see this
very small part of the spectrum
called visible light but a whole new
universe is revealed by looking through
the infrared
infrared light can't be seen but it can
be felt in the form of heat
every object whether hot or cold gives
off heat
special thermal cameras use colors to
show us if something is
warm or cold some objects are hot enough
to show
visible light and things that are too
cold to be seen by the naked eye
can let off in infrared such as your
body or this cup of coffee
ir light can be used in very practical
ways
longer ir waves can cook your dinner
shorter ir waves that are used in your
tv's remote control
and firemen use ir cameras to see
through smoke
to find people trapped in a fire so how
does this apply to a telescope
on top of showing us colder objects
infrared wavelengths can see through
large amounts of gas and dust lifting
the veil to what lies on the other side
spitzer sees objects like exoplanets or
the milky way
by looking at their infrared glow from
the heat they give off
this gives us the ability to see what is
beyond
and that's ir in a minute
if they're going to make something that
we don't know how to burn in a rocket
engine let's do some research
my name is diane linney and i am working
to build refineries and gas stations on
the moon and mars
one of the first things we need to do is
we need to dig up our dirt
i was working my vegetable garden using
a small rototiller the dirt was very dry
on top but of course as soon as i tilled
it up i got some
wet dirt and i thought wow we're trying
to harvest
the water out of the soil on the moon
and mars to
process it into something more useful we
get to play in our sandbox
we can measure how much soil went up
into the scoop
actually i wanted to be a lawyer when i
was in high school my high school
physics and calculus teacher said you're
a woman and you're really good at math
and science you should try engineering
up until now we've taken everything we
need with us we're trying to build
gas stations and refineries so we don't
have to bring all our propellant with us
our ancestors called it living off the
land it's just a lot of fun that we get
to try and push the technology and make
new things
[Music]
um
the complexity you know the systems that
we've brought together in this one place
to do something that
very few places in the world do you know
launch
launch humans to to low earth orbit and
you know
hopefully with a new program into you
know farther reaches of space
so when you go to a system or a place
like that you can't help it be
overwhelmed
every space shuttle mission began with a
fiery liftoff from launch complex 39 at
nasa's kennedy space center
the launch complex for the space shuttle
had two pads
pad a and pad b if the launch pads
demonstrated anything
it's that complex is the right word for
the two pad areas that handled the
shuttles for about a month
before they made their trips into space
outfitted with everything a spacecraft
and its crew would need to take the
final leap into space
the pads handled fueling duties and crew
support
and helped precision machinery for a
range of payloads
its graded floors and gray paint along
with armored boxes for instruments
telephones and elevators
revealed a style more spartan than space
age
you always find something that you
didn't know you've got
so many systems you've got system level
experts and technicians that have been
out there for so many years
you know dedicated essentially it's many
of them their entire careers
out there even though yeah it's a lot of
steel a lot of
wires and lights and tubing and that
kind of stuff
um it does enter it interfaces to
you know a flight vehicle you know so
you have those complex interfaces and
there's always something to learn it may
look kind of smart but yeah it's got its
hidden treasures
the launch pad and all its fittings were
built to withstand the brute force of a
launch
which would rattle the pad with intense
fire corrosive exhaust
and thunderous sound waves test it
let's put it that way there's a
tremendous amount of force that gets
placed you know on the
lift off on the structure on the mobile
launch platform the mlp
uh heat acoustics
each pad featured a shallow slope
concrete pyramid about 40 feet high with
a flame trench carved through the middle
to channel exhaust away during launch
launch pads were first built for the
saturn v rockets of the apollo program
back then the launch complex did not
have any permanent service towers
because the support structure was on a
mobile platform
and traveled with the rocket to the pad
the element of the history
you know to think back and to stand in
places where
people were launched to the moon that
has a
real a real place for me
for shuttle a pair of support structures
called a fixed service structure
or fss and a rotating surface structure
or rss were built as a pad and would
remain there for all 30 years of flights
both structures carried wiring and other
infrastructure
needed to support and protect the space
shuttle for weeks at a time
a shuttle stack meaning an orbiter
attached to an external fuel tank and a
pair of solid rocket boosters
would move to the launch pad about a
month before liftoff
shuttle was connected to networks of
data cables
water lines and the fueling system
unless you were out there when the
when the workers and technicians and
engineers were out there
you really it's hard to capture
the the elements of you know these
people working together as a team
doing complex tasks complex jobs
it with a with a vehicle there that's
just you know
loaded with solid propellant it could be
dangerous as heck
you know it really is i mean and they
did it routinely
and uh made it safe
there's also a bathroom complete with
stainless steel fixtures instead of
brittle porcelain
and when we do give a guy you know give
some tours up there groups come up there
i always point out that that's the last
toilet on earth
before launch day the rss covered most
of the shuttle
and provided a clean room that safely
moved space probes
space station modules and even nasa's
hubble space telescope into the
shuttle's cargo bay
without contaminating them other parts
of the launch pad
gave workers access to most areas of the
shuttle stack
which stood up to 184 feet above the
surface of the mobile launcher platform
the launch pad was woven throughout with
propellant lines
wiring and machinery there's so many
complex things out there that could
literally kill you you know
if you did something wrong or not just
yourself
you know it could be you know
devastating and uh
we do it safely routinely day in and day
out
that's testament to the workforce into
the
to what this nation built from the
apollo era
you know learning through hard lessons
launch day was also when most of the
structures of the pad came to life
mostly by remote control to keep people
a safe distance away
the huge white spheres on either side of
the shuttle will pump supercoal liquid
hydrogen and liquid oxygen
into the shuttle's external tank each
propellant had to flow through long
lines from the spheres about a half mile
from the shuttle
uh as you get closer to launch you know
things just kind of step up
and you just you can feel it and
just pure excitement you know really as
you're getting closer
the last people at the pad on launch day
were the astronauts
they headed into the white room kind of
cramped locker room
before boarding the shuttle with two and
a half minutes to go
the gaseous oxygen vent arm and its
white beanie cap retracted from the top
of the external tank
clearing the way for the launch about 16
seconds before launch
some 300 000 gallons of water poured
onto the launch pad
what might seem to be done to protect
against the blazing fire
the water was actually for sound
suppression to dampen the vibrations
produced
by seven million pounds of thrust
fire and thunder would produce a show
unlike any other
go for main engine start we have main
engines start
two one booster ignition
and the final liftoff of discovery a
tribute to the dedication
hard work and pride of america's space
shuttle team
the shuttle has cleared the tower
some of our team will work late shifts
so you kind of have to go home and
sometimes you know watch it from the the
river
just like the other the other folks
would or something like that which i i
actually
kind of enjoy you know if i couldn't
make it into center in time
you know just kind of being out there
with the general general public and
everything like that
just sit back and and watch the kids and
people enjoy a beautiful launch you know
this
was part of my joy i guess now that the
space shuttle is retired
the paths are being prepared for another
transition
the structures that mark the space
shuttle era have been removed from
launch pad 39b
so it can handle several different types
of launchers that are expected to make
up the next generation of space
exploration
pad 39a the starting point for some of
nasa's most famous flights including
apollo 11
and the first and last shuttle flights
will look as it did during the shuttle
years for the near term
echoing the thundering success of the
space shuttle program
go for maintenance and start we have
maintenance start
two one booster ignition
and the final liftoff of discovery two
solid rocket motors
that's pretty rough ride but you can
feel the thrust tail off
right before they separate and uh you
know you get an indication pc less than
50 and then you know you're gonna be
there two and two minutes five seconds
or so
they separate away there's a huge flash
in the front window a big bang you can
hear the set motors push those away
and then it's just as smooth as can be
on those main engines they're phenomenal
pieces
of machinery the space shuttle main
engines have been one of the brightest
success stories of the space shuttle's
30-year career
powered by a combination of fuel and
oxygen a single
ssma as the engines are called produces
about 500
000 pounds of thrust working with the
two solid rocket boosters for the first
two minutes of launch
three main engines push a shuttle up to
mach 25 and into orbit
in eight and a half minutes we call the
ssme an extreme machine and it's extreme
because
on the inlets you got liquid oxygen and
liquid hydrogen
and liquid hydrogens minus 420 degrees
fahrenheit so it's extremely cold
propellant
that we're putting through the turbo
machinery and then we're burning it in
the main combustion chamber at 6000
degrees fahrenheit
so that's hot enough to melt iron it can
do that without melting because the
engine pumps the cryogenic hydrogen
through a series of 1040
tubes lining the nozzle the super cold
fuel keeps the flames from touching the
sides of the nozzle
there also are a pair of turbo pumps
that move the propellants through the
machinery
and into the combustion chamber quickly
the turbo pumps alone
produce more power than a locomotive
even though they would fit on a desk
providing that amount of power safely
calls for extensive testing and
inspections of
each engine and their turbo pups a main
engine gets examined from the time the
shuttle lands
until liftoff highly trained technicians
use long flexible lenses called bore
scopes to look at each engine's insides
for cracks and other defects a skilled
technician engineer can perform a real
good boroscope inspection of bearings
seals and actually the turbine blades
nozzle beans pump blades
and diffusers the engine's success did
not come easy
engineers began testing engine designs
in 1975
at nasa's dennis space center in
mississippi
just getting the startup sequence right
took months and months of complex work
well of course the first test of the
space shuttle main engine on
a1 test stand was like 20 milliseconds
i mean it took a long time to develop
the start sequence of the engine and it
was 20 milliseconds at the time
finally 40 they worked their way up to
one and a half seconds which is a
critical time period in the thrust build
up of
the start sequence and then it just went
on from there and it took
a long time to actually finally get the
mainstay
the shuttle's main engines made their
first flight test on april 12
1981 along with the rest of the space
shuttle system
although the engines had been fired on
test stands no crew flew with them until
commander john young and pilot bob
crippen
rode them into orbit on sts-1 and when
that whole vehicle got together we put
the crew in and we counted down
and we saw engine ignition and all three
engines come up
it was just an extremely rewarding
experience to see that
and see the srbs fire and that whole
orbiter take off and fly
was you know hard to describe because of
all of the activities that i know led up
to that
and all the people involved in it to see
that as a successful mission because
we didn't have an opportunity to fly at
unmanned
before we flew at man so that's the
first time this country
really did an experiment with people on
board and it all worked
though the shuttle engines are smaller
than the mammoth f1
that powered the saturn v's first stage
they had to be far more efficient
and then this was the first time we had
to design an engine that would operate
for eight and a half minutes
in the apollo program the first stage
engines operate for about 200 seconds
and it basically gets you up to about 50
000 feet
or higher through the heavy atmosphere
and then the first stage is spent and
then the second stage takes over
in this case the ssme was designed to
start on the ground
have the ability to help check it before
the solid rocket motors behind
and then commit the launch and then stay
running all the all the way through
orbital injection velocity so that made
it run for eight and a half minutes so
that was different
than engines we had built previously
along with the brawn of hundreds of
thousands of pounds of thrust
the engines carry very delicate brains
that take constant measurements of the
systems
dozens of times every second this is the
first
engine we built that had an active
onboard digital computer
and the computer has a program in it
that runs through its
full cycle in 20 milliseconds 50 times a
second
it's out reading valve positions sensor
data
and we have algorithms in there that
allow that engine to have what we'll
call health monitoring
so we have active flight red lines that
in the event that temperature should
exceed the limit
that engine will automatically shut
itself down to prevent a catastrophic
failure
no mission ever failed because of a
space shuttle main engine
but a couple saw close calls during
launch
in 1985 one of the engines on space
shuttle challenger
picked up a problem so they actually
shut that engine down
at about 18 000 feet per second let the
other two engines
run the vehicle until it reached the
actual velocity required
to make orbit so it was a successful
mission and it just showed that
the redundancy built into the engines
really paid off
the space shuttle's main engines also
had a requirement no other engine faced
before
they had to be reusable reusability
created issues with
hardware and griddlemen it was hydrogen
molecules embedding themselves in the
material
causing embrittlement later on so that
created
life cycle issues and we were always
talking about what's the remaining life
in the hardware
the smes produce nothing but steam when
they fire
another departure from previous rocket
engines
[Music]
oxygen hydrogen when it when it combines
and creates water
it's very clean a lot different from the
apollo days when you had
liquid oxygen and kerosene well this
engine is extremely clean
and people are amazed when they look at
the engines in the shop that have flown
10 times or more they look brand new the
shuttle main engines have proven to be
extremely
reliable machines with a record of
reusability
and success without parallel in rocketry
but ssme is in a class all by itself
and of course the the reliability that
we get out the ssme is
is the reliability and the performance
that allows the shuttle to fly
as far as the extreme temperatures
the pressures they operate the fact that
they have been reusable
and so reliable for from sts-1 to
sts-135 i still write the main engines
at the top
[Music]
for two of nasa's story space shuttle
orbiters
the lights have gone out for the last
time discovery
and atlantis were permanently powered
down in december 2011
as teams at nasa's kennedy space center
in florida
prepare the vehicles for public display
it was an emotional milestone for the
technicians
test conductors and system engineers who
have spent years
even decades preparing each spacecraft
for its next flight
the final assignment for discoveries
processing team on december 16
2011 was to close the 60-foot long
payload bay doors many gathered for one
last look
inside the shuttle's payload bay even at
the smithsonian there's no plans to open
those payload doors on discovery so
as far as we know right now those doors
will never open again
then it was time for the spacecraft
operators on discovery's flight deck
to shut down the power
actually our center director bob cabana
was there so he actually pulled the plug
on that power up sign
and that was it for discovery december
22nd was the last day that work on
atlantis would require
power its starboard robotic arm and ku
band antenna
were stowed inside the payload bay for
the vehicle's upcoming move into
temporary storage
so we were anxious to get as much work
done on atlantis and get to a point
where we could then continue to do work
on atlantis
in the vehicle assembly building while
she was staged there
in a waiting mode then the focus turned
to the flight deck
as atlantis known by the shuttle team as
ov 104
was powered down for the last time
[Music]
lb-104 final power down is complete
discovery and atlantis have gone dark
but the team has one more power down to
get through
shuttle endeavour will be next it's sad
but you know progress you have to move
on
so something has to be done i'm
extremely proud to be a part of it till
the end
extreme
throughout the space shuttle program a
familiar launch day site
was the shiny silver vehicle known as
the astrovan
before each launch astronauts smiled and
waved as they left the crew quarters
and boarded the van that would carry
them to meet their fully fueled ride to
space
the vehicle had lined its way across
nasa's kennedy space center in florida
as it carried the crew to the launch pad
it was an exciting ride for the crew
members
but especially for the rookies ready for
their first trip to space
the first time it's just everything
about it is just you know the
anticipation
excitement you know you're a little bit
nervous
uh but it's uh i mean it's just neat
to know that you know you're one in the
series of a very long line of astronauts
abroad in this vehicle
going to the pad you know for flight to
space so it's pretty cool
early shuttle crews had fewer astronauts
so they rode to the launch pad in an
apollo era transport van
but since 1984 each shuttle crew
traveled those nine miles aboard the
current vehicle
the modified airstream motorhome only
racked up about 27
000 miles in its 27 years of service
that's because it's used solely to
transport the astronauts for each
mission
but i always associate this vehicle with
flying
because you only get in here twice you
get in here for tcdt which of course is
the launch
rehearsal and then launch day the only
other time the astra van was used
was to take the aft drop back the crew
quarters after landing
the vehicle's appeal is rooted in its
tradition rather than its decor
it's not really extravagant kind of like
bench seating and
it's pretty crowded on launch day
especially with a crew of seven you know
i think everyone's trying to
cut the tension with a joke or two from
time to time the interior's narrow
center aisle
is paralleled by long benches lift out
sections accommodate the ventilator
units
used to circulate cool air through the
astronauts bulky orange launch and entry
suits
this is the only place they have liquid
air and
liquid air is really really good you
know we have this uh this cooling
uh garment that circulates water cooling
and in the hot florida sun it's nice to
have it
they plug that liquid air into you and
it it just blows this cool air
throughout your suit which is really
nice because it actually dries your suit
and the only place we get to have it is
in here and i don't know why
it was like a special treat on launch
day now while each crew no doubt had
their own unique take on their ride to
the launch pad
shuttle atlantis sts-135 mission crew
took in the significance of the final
ride for the space shuttle program
it was really special this time because
there were so many people here
and i think uh even though it's kind of
an anxious time as you head out to the
launch pad because you know this might
actually be the day
on this particular day you know the last
flight i think we were all
really amazed at how many people showed
up
i mean even on the road you hang the
right turn to go to the pad and there
were the road was lined with people
waving american flies
it made me feel good you know to know
that
that the shuttle program meant this much
to so many people and not just national
but internationally
a lot of people turned out to watch
the you know the grand finale if you
would while the vehicle won't be taking
any more shuttle crews to the launch pad
nasa plans to keep it ready to ferry
future astronaut crews to the path
i would like to keep this tradition you
know i don't know if any of us will get
to fly on the next vehicle whatever that
vehicle may be a u.s vehicle
but it would be kind of neat to have
some of it be the same actually
traditions are important
because it keeps everybody connected
everybody ready
hold on everybody
so after riding the astrovan to the
launch pad a number of times
what would be like if a space shuttle
commander got the keys to take it for a
spin
sts-135 commander chris ferguson found
in a minute and a out that was the most
white-knuckled event i've had
i pronounce this vehicle fit for another
space program
[Music]
orion is getting ready to launch
my name is kelly smith and i work on
navigation and guidance for orion
orion is nasa's next generation
spacecraft built with versatility in
mind it can take astronauts deeper into
space than we've ever gone before
to an asteroid or even onto mars for
these missions
orion has to be one tough spacecraft
withstanding high speeds
searing temperatures and extreme
radiation
before we can send astronauts into space
on orion
we have to test all of its systems and
there's only one way to know if we got
it right
fly it in space for orion's first flight
no astronauts will be aboard the
spacecraft is loaded with sensors
to record and measure all aspects of the
flight in every detail
it all begins with launch aboard a delta
iv
heavy rocket
so
as it punches into earth orbit orion
will jettison its launch
board system the abort system is a
safety feature
designed to pull orion and its crew out
of danger if there were a problem with
the rocket during ascent
orion's journey is just beginning
[Music]
as the spacecraft and the upper stage
begin their first lap around earth
mission control in houston is monitoring
the progress of the flight
orion's over 100 miles up and going
about 17
000 miles per hour just as it passes
over the indian ocean
we lose communication
this is expected the communications link
we have through satellites to orion is
momentarily lost
but orion continues to receive and
process data
its computers can handle 480 million
instructions per second
imagine you are traveling with orion as
the flight test continues
one orbit completed time to go
the upper stage of the rocket fires
again like the setup for a roller
coaster ride this is the big climb we've
been waiting for
we are headed 3 600 miles above earth
15 times higher from the planet than the
international space station
as we get further away from earth we'll
pass through the van allen belts
an area of dangerous radiation
radiation like this could harm the
guidance systems onboard computers or
other electronics on orion
naturally we have to pass through this
danger zone twice
once up and once back
but orion has protection shielding will
be put to the test as the vehicle cuts
through the waves of radiation
sensors aboard will record radiation
levels for scientists to study
we must solve these challenges before we
send people through this region of space
for this flight it's time to head home
the upper stage of the rocket triggers
separation
orion's jets fire to turn it into the
proper position to re-enter earth's
atmosphere
no matter what happens now we're coming
in
75 miles above earth the spacecraft
enters the atmosphere
things happen quickly we're now
traveling more than 20 000 miles per
hour
air particles pushed out of the way heat
up an envelope of hot plasma surrounds
the vehicle
as it plummets towards earth the plasma
reaches temperatures of 4
000 degrees fahrenheit almost twice as
hot as molten lava
this may be the most dangerous part of
the flight mission control is monitoring
all the data from the spacecraft and
then
we lose communication again no data can
penetrate the plasma
orion is on its own
orion is inside a fireball onboard
systems ignite
jets to keep the ship pointed correctly
so the specially constructed heat shield
takes the full brunt of the inferno
this is the largest heat shield of its
kind ever made
orion's computers command the spacecraft
to bank like an airplane
keeping a precise path to the landing
site even though we've slowed from 20
000 miles per hour to about 300 miles
per hour
we're still traveling amazingly fast we
must slow down to safely land in the
ocean
luckily we have parachutes
especially designed for orion the
parachutes help us hit the brakes
but not too quickly one day people will
be aboard
so deceleration must happen in stages to
keep things comfortable for the crew
[Music]
the forward bay covered jettisons
two drogue shoots deployed and slow the
returning spacecraft down to 175 miles
per hour
[Applause]
then the three main parachutes open
once fully engaged this canopy would
cover an american football field
it takes parachutes this size and
strength to slow our descent to 20 miles
per hour
and then splash down
for this first flight we won't have
astronauts inside but we still have some
very precious cargo
the flight data from this mission is
stored inside the orion spacecraft
while our flight might be over there is
still a lot of work to do onboard
sensors recorded every detail
from launch to flying in space to
re-entry to landing
[Music]
flight tests are difficult and complex
but they give us confidence that the
systems we have designed
work under a real flight conditions it's
great to be a part of this first space
flight for orion
and we're looking forward to beginning a
new chapter in human
space exploration
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
nasa researchers spend weeks even months
at a time
in remote locations around the world
collecting critical data about earth's
environment
many studies are done from the air using
nasa's fleet of research aircraft
[Music]
one such mission is operation icebridge
a multi-year study of polar ice
conducted by the nasa airborne science
program
icebridge sends nasa's p3 flying
laboratory to greenland and alaska in
the spring
to study changing ice conditions in the
arctic
a second aircraft the nasa dc-8 flies
from punto arenas in southern chile in
the fall
to measure land and sea ice over
antarctica
it takes months of planning to execute a
major international mission
like ice bridge diplomatic clearances
configuring the aircraft with scientific
instruments
and finding facilities that can support
the people and the airplane itself
are just some of the preparations needed
for icebridge to meet its mission
requirements and goals
to deploy uh to some place like chile we
plan a good six months
before the mission to bring everything
together so that once you arrive you're
ready to execute missions on a daily
basis
typically admission director mission
manager program manager we get called
different names
we'll do the site surveys for the
location the liaisoning with the
government
from the host government to the host
airport
that's the real legwork that's done
prior is coming out
to make sure that it can house and feed
us and take care of the people the
hotels
you name it there's a lot of little tiny
details that
can't be overstated the biggest
logistical challenge
for the project as a whole is to set up
all of the lab space and the the
facilities so that the scientists can
process their data and make their
decisions
about which project logistics is huge
for something like this because we have
to make sure we can all
support the people in the field as well
as the aircraft so we
think a lot about aircraft spares and
then little details about the support
equipment for the airplane
usually on every deployment we're going
to there's at least a group that goes
out and scopes out
a lot of it's done like while we're
working other missions and they will
talk with the airfield set up and tell
them what we're going to be doing
and then as they're communicating back
with us with what capabilities the
airfield has to support us
that way we know what to ship for a
deployment more than six thousand miles
away in the southern hemisphere
the maintenance crew needs to carry an
extensive payload to maintain the dc-8
on site
and keep the mission on schedule
more than 13 000 pounds of cargo are
packed on the bc-8
everything from spare tires parts and
tools to basic comforts of home
for the mere daily 11 hour research
flights over antarctica
on a deployment like this we bring the
equipment with us and we also
ship a lot of other things by sea in a
big container
so that we can keep the airplane moving
it'll come back from a mission if
there's anything wrong that needs to be
repaired before the next flight
we have the maintenance crew to support
it during the night
and get it ready for a mission the
following day
[Applause]
the dc-8 flight operations team works
around the clock to support operation
icebridge
providing ground support for takeoffs
and landings operating the plane on
research flights
and making sure sensitive science
instruments stay powered up
and heated overnight the airfield is
staffed
24 hours a day we have a makeup of about
28 people supporting the flight
operations down here
and that consists of the pilots flight
engineers navigators
mission directors and then the
maintenance crew split between mechanics
and the avionics technicians
[Music]
the maintenance team often works on
tight deadlines to prepare the aircraft
for its next deployment
just 10 days after removing one set of
science instruments from a previous
mission
the dc-8 is reconfigured for icebridge
in three weeks time the plane is
transformed into a working science
laboratory
with a suite of radar and laser
instruments and cameras
installed throughout the cabin cargo pit
and fuselage
yeah the unique thing about the dc-8 is
that it was modified
to accept uh at this point we've got
about 100 different instruments have
been integrated into this airframe
and so part of the modifications that
were done early on
was to make the airplanes versatile as
possible
so if you were to look through the
airframe you'd see cutouts in both the
bottom of the aircraft and the upper
side of the aircraft
and a number of the windows were
modified to carry structural loads of
instruments being installed as well
so we can look in pretty much every
direction there is outside this airplane
as we're traveling to the sky
once the science instruments are
installed the flight operations team
conducts a series of ground checks and
instrument test flights over the
california desert
to make sure the dc-8 is mission ready
looks like maybe it's level now
all right looks like it's our wings
level and rock
so the reason why we picked these sights
over the
desert in california is because they
have these dry
lake beds there and they are a very flat
area that's ideally suited for our
purpose
so we can put a gps receiver on a car
and kind of drive around on these flat
late beds
measure them and then a few days later
fly over the same area with the dc-8 and
take a measurement from the air
compare the two measurements and use the
data from the ground to
calibrate and validate the the air-1
measurements while the aircraft is
prepared for the trip to chile
the science and flight operations teams
are required to undergo specialized
safety training
regardless of if they've flown on the
dc-8 in the past
well for the dc-8 everybody who flies
has to go through
basically a safety briefing we go in a
little bit more detail because we do
more things on our airplanes than
commercial airliners do
from our pilots you know they go through
survival training
water and land and depending on where
they're going
some of them been through arctic all of
our crew members
they all have to go to altitude chamber
water survival land survival
and what we do here is we just build on
that and then try and bring anybody else
that hasn't had any formal training
up to speed so they have at least a
working knowledge of
the kind of conditions that can happen
when if something was to go wrong with
the aircraft
safety equipment tailored for icebridge
is also packed on the dc-8
overhead compartments we've got the
20-man life rafts there's four of those
on board the aircraft
we have two what we call global survival
kits which has
different survival items inside of there
for this particular deployment we also
have anti-exposure suits
which uh if they were going to the water
we have
enough for everybody on board there
after that
once the aircraft and passengers are
cleared to fly
it's time to pack up for the long
transit flight from armstrong flight
research center in california
to the southern tip of chile
the exhausted team gets an opportunity
to rest on the overnight journey to
santiago
where a second flight crew is on standby
to complete the journey to punto arenas
to get to this part of the globe it's
about
14 hours of flying uh we had
pre-deployed a crew to santiago
uh to join the flight at that point so
the crew that flew all night
could then step out of the cockpit and
rest and that'll allow us to continue on
that next day down to uh puntarenas
chile with him to stop overnight
it's a cold and windy welcome at the
punta arenas airport
the mission base for operation ice
bridge
the scientists and flight crew will call
this place home until the end of
november
we are setting up base stations here at
the airport that record the gps data for
various instruments
we're talking to people in the weather
office at the
tower the air traffic controllers and
that typically takes about a day
and getting everybody settled in here
and preparing everything for the
first science flight with two complete
flight crews available
science flights are planned on
consecutive days to collect as much data
as possible over antarctica
on a typical ponte arenas deployment we
have about
300 flight hours and if we
fly as much as we can which we typically
do
we kind of travel a distance in
antarctica that's equivalent to three or
four times around the
equators i don't i think this is the
glacier we're crossing
flight tracks are carefully designed by
the icebridge science team
months in advance survey lines need to
be precise
not only to make repeat measurements in
exact locations
but also to ensure the plane keeps a
safe distance from specially protected
areas and animal habitats
a sophisticated guidance system on the
dc-8 helps the flight crew keep the
plane on track
and navigate around more than 1700 known
wildlife locations on the antarctic
continent
some of the flights are hand flown using
moving map displays that
have a flight track depicted on them
others are guided by
what's called the atm instrument where
it actually puts out a signal that we
feed into the aircraft navigation system
where it guides the airplane laterally
so the atm stands for airborne
topographic mapper
we designed a supplemental system to the
atm
some people call it the atm navigator
what it does is it couples into the
aircraft's
own autopilot and helps it to steer the
aircraft
as accurate as we need it to be we can
generally
steer the airplane well within 100 feet
and often within 20 feet
of where we want it to be and that means
that if you imagine
a line that represents our desired track
more than half the time that line will
lie within the cabin
of the aircraft antarctica's harsh and
often unpredictable weather
determines when and where the icebridge
team will fly each day
i've got rising terrain 12 o'clock seven
miles valley hill
tally ho and i'm going to start climbing
here
pilots need perfect visibility of the
terrain for safety
we're clear it does get steeper as we
get closer to it
pitch up a little bit several science
instruments need a clear line of sight
between the aircraft and the ground
to collect proper measurements
meteorology is obviously a very big deal
with icebridge
it's it essentially governs everything
that we do on any given day
we have to fly down low and near the
terrain in order for our instruments to
work
as they're optimally designed to work so
it means we need uh
clear skies below the altitude at which
we're operating
in order to do this kind of work we know
from experience which parts of
antarctica
are likely to have good weather and
which parts are not so we designed the
missions so that
each of the missions has a maximum
chance of success based on the likely
weather scenarios
we come up with about twice as many
mission plans as we can possibly fly in
the field
that's simply so that we have enough
target areas to choose from
that have good weather while we are here
in the field and then we
prioritize these plans we have to spend
a very large amount of our time while
we're in the field
trying to sort of ascertain what the
weather is going to do
it's a bit like reading tea leaves uh
it's a it's a very inexact science
we depend entirely on what the
meteorologists tell us
through computer models we talk a lot to
the
to the meteorologists here at the
airport they're terrific they give us a
lot of help
the chilean hosts provide everything
from weather expertise
to daily flight lunches for the
icebridge team
airport firefighters and emergency
responders are also prepared to help
in case anything goes wrong with the
aircraft so we don't use retread tires
the dc-8 is not your typical airplane
structural enhancements new engines and
cutting-edge data systems
make the aircraft a versatile long
endurance platform for earth science
research
dc-8 is uniquely capable for this kind
of operation
mainly because of its long legs it can
fly for about 14 hours on a full fuel
load
we have to pretty much commute every day
to antarctica and commute back
and then we need also the capability of
collect several hours of data
typically on every flight we collect
several terabytes of data all together
so we have eight different
science instruments on the aircraft and
in total it's a very complex
set of measurements that we take over
ice sheets and doing it all at the same
time
in the same location from one airplane
it's a really a tremendous resource
it is amazing that uh a large airplane
was designed originally to be an
airliner could be so diverse
but by its design it meets a lot of the
requirements nasa had set
for the type of science studies they
wanted to execute using an airplane to
support this particular airplane was
built in 1969
but many of the systems have been
upgraded over the years to keep up with
current technology
for instance the airplane has a
satellite communication system on it
which something like that didn't even
exist when it was originally built
so what's nice about that is we can move
data
real time during the flights off the
airplane to people anywhere in the world
via the satellite system and then the
internet
and they can send us information real
time as well
we can xchat it's like texting back and
forth to each other we can send
photographs we can send technical data
you don't have to actually be on the
flight to participate
my view of this airplane is that it's
the ideal airplane for the kind of
mission we use it for
because it's uh built very strong
and uh in the old days when these were
being designed and built the airplanes
were overbuilt
to be on the safe side we have a
nickname for it it's a dc-8 and the dc
stands for douglas
cable car because unlike the modern
airplanes that use electronics and
hydraulics to control the airplane in
flight
this airplane is controlled with steel
cables
so we do hurricane research we fly
through hurricanes
and we do a lot of different types of
scientific research
and the airplane can take a lot of
damage that would [ __ ] other more
modern airplanes
and this airplane still flies fine it's
like an old truck
it's solid and almost indestructible
a wall of stickers at the mission
director's console tells the story of
the many missions the dc-8 has flown
since it went into nasa's service in
1987.
this aircraft and many others operated
by the nasa airborne science program
fly thousands of hours every year all
over the world
to support a variety of earth science
research missions
it takes careful coordination and
detailed planning behind the scenes to
make these missions possible
and to gain a better understanding of
how our planet is changing
[Music]
i've always thought like oh my gosh when
you go to space like you don't have to
grocery shop for like
six months i think it's gonna actually
put me on a schedule for eating
i am horrible at eating at all hours of
the night i missed one
we're also talking about like beverages
like we can probably only drink
powdered beverages or water so nothing
no sodas
nothing carbonated yeah
i think it'll be a little bit more
healthy than what i normally eat
plus i get to eat everything with
tortillas and i'm from san antonio so
i will say we are doing this over a
holiday weekend we have huge barbecues
and
lots of great food so i think i'm going
to want to eat some really good ribs and
you know
like [ __ ] uh solidly swear to eat all
the astronaut food and not
cheat never never we're in this together
so if we feel we're never ever
we'll text each other maybe we chose
seven days
out of the standard menu you're gonna
have a protein some carb
some fruit the other large category of
products that we have
are thermo stabilized products which is
a sort of like a military ration that we
don't have to
uh refrigerate uh to keep fresh can't do
them in the microwave because they can
literally
like something that can't go in the
microwave i was gonna ask because i
didn't want to flatten that out the hard
drive yeah
we also have rehydratable food which is
this type in a vacuum pack where we have
to add water
either hot or cold we're going to give
you
a syringe i don't like needles
and it comes with a needle
this is so hydrated okay i don't think
we would want to have that laying around
can i take dandruff it is the day before
we start the food challenge
and i just went to go pick up all the
materials from our wonderful food lab
so they're all packaged in my trunk i
asked them what i should eat as my last
uh real meal and they said something
fresh maybe a salad
the problem is i was thinking nachos so
as i suspected i wouldn't have time to
eat in the airport i'm probably going to
grab
something to eat on the fly
hopefully there's some tacos so like i
said i was debating healthy
or you know not healthy of course
uh i chose nachos i did end up picking
up some tacos some shrimp tacos actually
with some rice and some beans
um i told you i love tacos it's
important to always choose nachos so i'm
gonna call this
hashtag she chose nachos she chose
nachos he chose tacos
so i have beef and mushrooms
rice pilaf tomato and artichokes and a
wheat
i don't know about that i have grilled
chicken
mac and cheese vegetarian chewy we're in
texas
come on cran apple dessert oh man i
already
remember she told us to tear it so
there's no extra pieces of trash
oh so like if we were in space this
would all be floating around
yeah once we open those packages the
food is what we
consider to be liberated and it can just
float anywhere and sometimes you find
yourself
using your spoon or your mouth to chase
around the food
make sure you get it all in your mouth
instead of stuck against the wall or
somebody's face
let's heat up a bowl of water and set
these green ones in there yeah
and it looks like it's getting to be the
right consistency yeah
we might have not done hot enough water
too that might be why it's not absorbing
like
all the way okay this is good this is
interesting
it's not bad wait a minute
oh this is good yeah the artichokes and
try and eat it like this yeah
you should just got straws right this is
making my day like
this is a treat i have cranapple desert
this would
remind me of home yum
so it's been a long day but i did not
get hungry at all i had my butterscotch
pudding as part one of my snacks
wondering if the workouts would be hard
they're pretty much the same i feel
really high energy and i didn't even
have coffee this morning i'm actually
really excited about this chicken corn
and bean
this potato medley actually looks like
some potatoes with spices and melted
cheese on it i'm very excited to get
some melted cheese texture up in here
little butter cookies look really
delicious and super bougie
so you'll see i have some caribbean
chicken pesto pasta with some corn
tortillas
vanilla pudding and some pears i got a
little bit better at actually making the
space food today
but i punctured the the actual corn i
cut through it
so i had to rehydrate it through the
side um so lesson learned
this smells absolutely delicious
it's my boyfriend's last day at his old
job so one of his favorite clients
brought him these delicious huge looking
cupcakes so none for me
[Music]
do you see that this is science y'all
so you're nurse now
my mom would be proud like mom i'm doing
nurse things today
oh okay this looks like oatmeal do pr
for nasa they said it'd be fun
be having for lunch what's your your
main i have citrus salad
and then my main thing is fiesta chicken
i love fiesta yeah and rice yeah yeah
rice with butter
i'm really excited because i think our
food's going to be warmer today i agree
i think we did this right with some
practice yesterday
[Music]
this is some smoked turkey
[Laughter]
and then some cauliflower i'm not a fan
of this
um today we're eating in the lbj room so
president lbj um is who johnson space
center is named after
we should do a toast we should go lbj
oh mine's closed and so here we go
this is really good this is the the
chicken noodles let's try some of this
green bean
oh that could use some hot sauce the
lentil soup
hot oh hot
see um these are actually my tortillas
astronauts onboard the international
space station
can actually eat tortillas and it's one
of the things that they like to do
because you can pretty much grab
anything that's floating in space with
them
two quick miscellaneous notes i've been
living a really scheduled life and
waking up early and going to bed early
because i've been having to wake up
with enough time to make breakfast and
then i go to bed shortly after dinner
just so i don't get hungry
again i think dan has a burrito oh yeah
i went for peach there's some queso
[Music]
fresh which may or may not be organic
[Music]
there you go lemon curd cake
looks kind of like your rice
[Music]
i was just at the mall and that was a
week time because all of my friends i
got some really good appetizers and when
you're just all sitting around the table
together it's i had to really stop
myself a couple times and not mindlessly
uh reach for some of their chips or
pretzels
what are you eating a cupcake and what
is a sidro eating
space chocolate chocolate yeah
how do you feel about the astronaut
[Music]
can you tell which one's the space food
and which one is
our regular easter meal here hey guys
what are y'all making
astronaut burgers i feel like a piece of
delicious grilled food and i get to eat
a kind of brisket it's space brisket and
baked
barbecue beans so we'll see how that
ends up see this oh it's coming apart
it's monday so we're done wednesday
morning we're really ready to be done
the weekend was hard
i was not able to eat any of the food
that was at the festival
there were some jalapeno corn dogs and
i'm like sounds so good what is life
right now i
can't even and we have curry chicken
green beans and potatoes the potatoes
have been empty but these look better
than some of the ones
cream of mushroom soup oh a little bit
of india
a little bit of texas with this
countriness so we're ready for this to
go yeah we're ready
i need my social life now yeah no i'm
just having milk today
buttered milk
i'm more nervous about the milk i'm not
gonna lie
um but something that i noticed while
we've been eating this food is you have
to have it really hot
on the space station we put it in a kind
of a it's almost like an easy bake oven
okay where you just and that does make a
really big difference
so i gotta admit when i was making
lunches when i wasn't thinking this
would be on camera
leftover rice some turkey but it's home
cooked
it's definitely hot yeah i was a big fan
of the garlic paste
garlic paste i could fix anything okay
question can you chew gummy spice
yes okay because garlic you know bad
bread
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we would use what we call food glue
something
just make it make upset spray some olive
oil in there and try to get everything
to stick together a little bit or like i
said the garlic paste worked well for me
but when you get a few people with rice
in their eye and then
figure something out you know it's a lot
easier in space because we don't have to
load the syringe like if you were trying
to measure out 250 milliliters of water
or 100 milliliters of water we literally
just dial that number
and then press the button for hot or
cold water talk to me
about tacos in space tortillas are they
grapes to have up there
yeah oh sorry it just floated on this
plate
gosh we had salsa we did have salsa
sometimes you put that on there the
sauce will stick to the bread
you can use the salsa for other things
to stick to the salsa i'm from san
antonio
i love tacos so i told everyone i would
make it
space socks so it's a little bit leaky
extra moist just rip off the edges it
just makes a bubble gotta do the tackle
tilt
everybody knows
good stuff that's awesome this was the
mexican scrambled eggs food lab
they know what they're doing we have
some scientists back there
so is there anything
[Music]
way better than the lbj toast yeah
favorite meal i actually really liked a
lot of the breakfast food
um and the shrimp cocktail was in fact
very good ooh shrimp cocktail
but the scrambled eggs in a taco
ugh man sorry it's done and maybe if i
had a machine to kind of heat everything
up
if i was sealed away from the outside
world and i didn't have all those
temptations
maybe maybe if the food was floating
around me but i don't think i would
otherwise
if i were an astronaut so i was debating
this is the same debate i started with
nachos or a salad
get them both yeah i'll get both of them
yeah i think we need to treat
ourselves oh for sure but i can tell you
i really want some coffee
regular coffee coffee
[Music]
this is not easy y'all i'm telling you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
imagine living in a modern metropolis
full of opportunities
endless sunshine hollywood celebrities
and fancy cars that
was the american dream that was los
angeles
in the early 1940s
but in the morning of july 26 1943
in the middle of world war ii the sun
didn't rise over the city a
throat-burning
noxious gas covered the sky
entire city blocks faded away
a thick fog that made people's eyes
sting
and their noses run had taken hold
of the city they were under attack
or so they thought at the time
[Music]
but the attack didn't come from the
outside
massive wartime production facilities a
high increase in population
and the exhaust fumes of cars combined
with the geography of the valley
made the city a trap or air pollution
[Music]
the day after the first event city
officials tried to control the damage
by restricting emissions from power
plants and industry
but while these efforts help reduce air
pollution smog episodes continue to
occur
scientists discovered that volatile
compounds like the gas is produced
due to evaporation of gasoline during
the refining process
and nitrogen oxides generated during the
combustion
inside car engines both reacted with
sunlight
creating a highly toxic gas ozone
and sunlight isn't precisely something
southern california lacks
[Music]
but this wasn't a localized phenomenon
other u.s cities
also experienced high ozone
concentration levels
these cases made society aware of the
importance
of keeping track of emissions and lead
politicians to implement policies
to improve the quality of the air we all
breed
air quality is a serious global problem
more than seven million people
die per year due to the effects of air
quality
there's many economies around the world
that are growing and
what the united states has seen is that
your economy can still grow while your
air pollution levels are decreasing
but it takes some effort to do that
the good news is that air pollution
levels around the world are gradually
decreasing
in fact air quality trends have improved
in the last decade
as a result of policies developed to
reduce air pollution
back in the 1950s los angeles had a
really
awful air quality problem so when the
clean air act began it was a commitment
to cleaning up the air
but the actual legislation and the
differences took a long time to put into
place
and so here in asia we're at the
beginning of that process these nations
that
are still increasing in their
standard of living and increasing their
pollution levels can learn from what's
happened in the industrialized nations
we can have a more rapid decrease in
pollution levels
now we know how to put together
effective policies to control air
quality
understanding that economic growth and
industrial development bring air quality
problems
and knowing how to deal with it in the
future is vital for us to keep
progressing
as a society now we have better tools
better technology and more knowledge we
can act
faster and more efficiently to address
pollution issues
[Music]
forest aq is an international
cooperative field campaign between nasa
and the korean national institute for
environmental research
ministry of environmental career has put
in a great deal of effort
into improving our quality by working
with our korean
colleagues we've been able to design a
campaign that
is very specific to their knowledge of
the air quality problem for the past
decades
joint venture with nasa has provided us
with many research
opportunities
the air in our planet does not know of
national borders
or countries
a worldwide effort is needed so that
what we do in the name of progress
does not have a negative impact on our
health and helps preserve the only home
we know
earth horse aq combines
satellite type observations with ground
observations
and airborne observations to create the
most complete picture of air quality
we've ever created
explore with us take a deep breath and
join us on an expedition
that will investigate a major public
health problem
air pollution
one of the difficulties in understanding
air quality is that
the pollution that affects your health
the most is not the initial component
put into the atmosphere
under certain atmosphere conditions some
of these pollutants react with each
other
and produce new harmful agents like
ozone
there's three key ingredients to make
ozone nox
hydrocarbons and sunlight so think think
of ozone as an important cleansing agent
from the atmosphere
when you have a big stain to clean you
use a lot of cleanser and when you
create a lot of pollution
a lot of ozone becomes evident in the
atmosphere that's helping to clean the
atmosphere
but it's also impacting our health
[Music]
we have primary pollutants nitrogen
oxides and
reactive hydrocarbons are most important
in the formation of ozone your car
emits both nox and hydrocarbons to
unburn fuel
but the ozone itself comes from the
chemistry so we call it a secondary
pollutant because it results from
the chemistry that occurs after the
emission of the nitrogen oxides and the
reactive hydrocarbons
when nitrogen oxides and hydrocarbons
react with sunlight
they produce a harmful secondary
pollutant
ozone but wait
isn't ozone good for us well it depends
the role of ozone in the atmosphere is
quite complex and the stratosphere ozone
is a great benefit because it protects
us from uv radiation
in the lower atmosphere ozone is also a
benefit because it's responsible
for initiating the chemistry that
cleanses the pollution out
but when pollution levels are very high
the chemistry runs amok and you create
very high levels of ozone and those
ozone levels can become so high
that they become reactive with their own
body tissues and become a problem in
terms of health
photochemical smog is considered to be a
problem of modern industrialization
it is present in all modern cities but
it is more common in cities with sunny
warm dry climates and a large number of
motor vehicles
it can also affect rural areas where
agriculture
trees and forest fires can release a
considerable amount of volatile
organic compounds or vocs
[Music]
what are the sources of vocs well we
have just the evaporation of gasoline
when you're filling your tank
petrochemical plants the refineries that
are making
gasoline from for us from oil and also
the plastic companies that are making
plastics polyethylene polypropylene
in terms of reactive nitrogen man's
activity far outpaces the natural
sources and so we can say that when
nitrogen oxides are present
that's man when you talk about reactive
hydrocarbons
actually vegetation plays a major global
role in creating them
trees can emit that pine tree smell you
smell
but also a lot of the deciduous trees
are emitting isoprene isoprene is very
active and very good at making both
particles and ozone but fortunately
they create very specific molecules and
when man creates pollution
it creates a different chemical mix and
so we can look at
the constituents of the reactive
hydrocarbons to determine whether it's
nature
or whether it's man but because these
compounds travel with the wind
they can affect different parts of the
world
[Music]
recently scientists from other airborne
campaigns
were able to trace the origin of unusual
high levels of ozone in the air above
the western pacific ocean
they found that they were linked to the
organic compounds released by forest
fires in southeast asia
and africa half a world away
the atmosphere is a shared resource and
we're seeing more and more that the
entire northern hemisphere
is suffering from pollution and
background levels that are due to all of
us not just one
everyone living in a big city around the
world is breathing uh polluted air
and it is having an impact it's part of
the tug of war between progress
and and the price that we pay for that
progress and so that balance needs to be
maintained into the future
as we continue to develop economically
develop technologically
we have to pay attention to how that's
impacting air quality
our world is an interconnected system
and the impact of air pollution
goes beyond the air we breathe
all of the processes that are emitting
and causing air pollution also putting
co2 into the atmosphere causing
climate change global warming it also
affects our soils
our glaciers our oceans our
climate and this is a problem
that's going to affect our children and
our grandchildren
so it's very selfish of us to ignore
this long-term problem that is created
by us
[Music]
in a laboratory setting you can
artificially control different parts of
the problem so each effect can be
isolated
that's hard to find in nature
seoul south korea
a mega city with over 25 million people
and a population density which is almost
twice that of new york
and eight times greater than rome
despite being a modern and massive mega
city south korea still counts with many
forests and rural farming communities
throughout the country
but why is south korea an ideal natural
laboratory
to carry out air quality studies
we have a bunch of factors we have a
very large city a mega city the fourth
largest city on the planet
with lots of cars lots of power plants
and then downwind from that we have a
forest
so we have the urban plume reacting with
the natural emissions from the forest
this is a perfect place on the globe to
try to understand how the mixture
between man's
emissions and nature's emissions can
create poor air quality
[Music]
air pollution is an important
environmental problem in modern
societies
[Music]
the rapid growth of new economies and
industries in developing countries
makes it very difficult to address
environmental issues
korea has been developed very quickly
after korean war
actually economic success gave us lots
of benefits to the people
however this also brought many
environmental issues
including air quality so general public
has been known
about the yellow dust issue before and
in recent they start to learn about the
fine particle issues and ozone issues
they're starting to pay their attention
to those newer newer issues
emerging to our society korean
government has been making persistent
effort to improve our quality
we participate in this project as though
understanding of current situation
with area ground shape
on the type of current simple ground
observation crucial in future improving
equality
we are definitely paid attention to
solve this issue and general public
wants to know how we can actually
achieve that goal
developing effective strategies to
balance the economic growth and the good
health of the population
is key to continue growing and
prospering as a society
unfortunately policy always lags
emissions
and so it usually takes time to
understand what's causing the poor air
quality and then regulations can take
effect it's a tough problem we haven't
solved it completely in the us
but here i think you're right we're
learning a lot more about the specific
sources in this area so that
here locally the government can decide
what's the most effective strategies to
use because we don't want to
hinder economic development we just want
to know what are the smartest choices
you can make so you get the best
bang for the buck in the united states
in europe this has taken place over a
long period of time
things in asia are growing very rapidly
and so we're in the middle of that
process
but the difference is that now with our
knowledge and technology
we are better prepared to address these
complex environmental issues
in this case many countries in east asia
have been developing very quickly as
well because eco mission
makes people aware of the seriousness of
current air pollution so we are thinking
based on this mission
more general understanding getting
better and better
and eventually we can find something to
actually reflect to the strategy
chorus aq mission results will help
develop improved ways to assess
this challenging task
current investigation will definitely
help us gain deeper understanding of air
pollution phenomenon in global
[Music]
scale
[Music]
this is a lab measuring instrumentation
probes sensors gas and liquid chemicals
computers yeah
this is a lab but maybe not the lab you
would expect
meet the nasa dc-8 airborne laboratory
the airplane is designed for different
instrumentation suites depending on the
the missions that we fly so we have
multiple
zenith ports that look up we have
multiple nader ports that look down and
of course many of the window blanks
there
[Music]
there are 25 instruments on board the
aircraft not only from nasa but from
many universities and other
government labs and organizations and
together they paint a picture of the
atmosphere
that can allow us to completely evaluate
what emission sources in the peninsula
are contributing to poor air quality
and how the chemistry actually works in
terms of the outcome at the end of the
day when ozone
and particles are such a concern yeah
this integration is about as big as we
do and if you've
seen on onboard the airplane you can see
it's very full with all the all the
racks and
most of the windows you know covered
with the with the in-situ probes that
are there
the chorus aq campaign will gather air
quality data
in and around the korean peninsula from
multiple sources
such as ground stations and maritime
sensors however
the korus aq aircraft will be the ones
to provide the most
detailed information over a larger
geographical
area and at different altitudes
so in order to understand how it all
works we have several aircraft that we
have to fly
one is the one i'm standing on right now
the nasa dc-8
the dc-8's role is to measure the
atmosphere directly
from this aircraft we can measure
literally over 100 different compounds
in the atmosphere
the airplane flies as easily at 500 feet
as it does at
at higher altitudes that enables us to
do both
remote sensing which is using radars or
lidars
as well as as we can fly lower we can do
vertical profiles with our in-situ
sensors which
is currently what we got mostly on this
airplane in order to understand the
atmosphere there are many different
molecules that we have to measure
the satellite will not see all of them
and so by being able to measure what the
satellite will see
and at the same time see all of the
details we can begin to understand
what sources and what meteorologies and
what combinations of conditions
will affect what we see from space by
combining detailed measurements from
aircraft with those made by satellites
we can get a better picture of
pollutants in our atmosphere
so this aircraft carries instruments
that work just like the satellite
instruments
the higher we fly the wider the patch of
earth
we can see during the campaign nasa
king air aircraft will mimic the
measurements future satellites will make
we fly at about 28 000 feet and at that
altitude
we see about a 5